listen guys we've made news and we've
made fake news Okay help me out I have
no idea what you're talking about
remember when we did the Conan O'Brien
needs a fan episode with Smith mullikin
the guy who's responsible for the
shipping manifest of things that go up
to space Oh yes and we joked what could
you send up and Sona said space porn and
then we got into a conversation about
[ __ ] in space I said if one male
astronaut jizz is in space he could get
up to three female astronauts pregnant
right right well now news outlets picked
this up and started presenting it as
news and when I say news outlets I mean
real rags like the New York Post and a
bunch of others in the New York Times
clickbait and CNN
so the best part about this is that
Snopes had to do an entry on it now
snopes is the fact checking site that
people go to to find out if something is
real or not I've been a donor to this
site before I love this site and I'm so
happy to be on there but also bummed to
be on there as one of the people you
know blamed for fake news well help me
because you're not being quite clear
here you're saying that people reporting
that this did happen that three
astronauts got pregnant I'll clarify
okay here's the Snopes article itself
claim a NASA scientist warned astronauts
against masturbating in space because
they could accidentally impregnate
multiple women at once rating false fact
check in July 2022 several news sites
published articles claiming that a NASA
scientist had recently issued a warning
to astronauts against masturbating in
space because it allegedly could
impregnate multiple women the New York
Post for example published an article
headlined astronauts should not
masturbate in zero gravity NASA
scientist says the Daily Star ran away
with astronauts warned not to masturbate
in space as one session can impregnate
three females
these headlines are absurd NASA has
issued no such warning to his astronauts
these articles were based on a joke that
was told by a comedian during a recent
episode of Conan O'Brien's podcast Conan
O'Brien needs a friend on July 21st an
episode of the podcast titled space porn
was released on various podcast
platforms the episode featured Conan
Coho sonid mobsessian and Matt Gourley
and guest Smith mullikin a mechanical
engineer who works with a NASA
contractor in Houston Texas during the
episode Conan asked mullikin about what
sort of items can be shipped up to the
International Space Station as the host
mulled ideas about the strangest items
that could be shipped to space co-host
mosesian asked if he'd ever sent porn
and discussion oh man
replied none of that the Curious hosts
were not satisfied with this answer
however and continued to joke about porn
and masturbation in space at one point
Gourley who is a comedian now they
should Factor okay that
that's the fake news yes I know that is
the to me
that's the part that has me and Ryan I
get called a scientist later too I'm
loving this all right at one point Gorly
who's a comedian and not a NASA
scientist joked that three female
astronauts could be impregnated at the
same time if an astronaut were to
masturbate in space Here's the exchange
Conan where someone to be watching space
porn on the space station how does that
work Gorly three female astronauts can
be impregnated by the same man from the
same session Conan because the semen
flies around corally uh-huh and finds
its way mobsesian and the women are all
naked Gourley well it's space porn
mullikin who is not directly employed by
NASA was not an active participant in
this portion of the conversation this
was a brief I'm glad that we cleared him
if we've done nothing else we've cleared
him of all charges this was a brief
exchange by three comedians however no
it was not an exchange by there's one
comedian here then there's Sona well I
don't know what you're my assistant yeah
and Corley I don't know what you are
you're just an imp you're a Troublesome
imp no but you are not a comedian
however when this conversation was
recounted in the pages of the New York
Post the site misquoted this section and
claimed that the science that the
scientists had issued this warning about
multiple women getting pregnant the
scientists in the concluding sentence
was actually comedian gorley okay listen
you've got to stop is there more to read
just just to sum up that NASA has not
issued this guideline and there is even
I believe some proof or some evidence
that the Russians wanted astronauts to
try that in space but there might be
some logistical problems to having sex
with someone in space because of lack of
gravity has an impact on blood flow so
that's that's just the fact of it all
okay
um well let's that's all neither here
nor there I think we should attack uh
what's happened in the media there are
many uh instances of fake news uh in the
media
um I don't think this is that egregious
because I think we brought up a
legitimate point and uh I think that
astronauts should be warned we don't
know science doesn't know what's going
to happen
if space porn somehow invades the
International Space Station well now
isn't this reason for them to find out
like now there's a now we need to know
well I'm pretty sure the Russians have
figured it out already we just need them
to share yes okay someone needs to just
but can I say something this is
um
what's clear to me is that we were
talking about an interesting subject in
an erudite way then you mentioned you
take it to porn this isn't just my fault
Sona you brought it to porn and then
um the uh the Imp over here excuse me no
you are neither a comedian or a
scientist
um you bring it to uh semen and it's all
the low Arts it's the low-hanging fruit
you're also quoted in that Snopes
article as carrying this conversation
forward
all I'm doing in that conversation is
trying to get some clarity but I did not
introduce those topics I was trying to
keep it more towards what are the fun
innocent things that could be brought to
the space station or put into space you
were the guys that brought it Sona you
with porn and then you alley-ooped it
over this creep who took it to jizz
mountain and then that's where we are
that's where we are did you just say
just Mountain yeah you are no no can
people get pregnant on jizz Mountain you
can but the man has to be at the top and
the women have to be at a slight grade
below them so it could run down okay
Jesus now news outlets if you're
listening this is very important yeah
the thinner the jizz yeah okay that's
great
um well this is what we have this is
this is what we have and because we have
her to this okay
shows that you're still employed
that's the captain is that you're still
it's the the cappers that you're still
employed but you're still here and
you're going to you get a comedian and a
scientist and you're paying for one oh
my God you act like you're above this
yeah
I sit You Are I Am the great Pharaoh who
stands atop no the pyramid and watches
you guys slinging jizz down at the
bottom of the pyramid we've got a Capper
for this okay
so you know that this is real news Joe
Rogan has put it on his Instagram oh the
headline from one of the Articles that's
fantastic yeah that's great well I um we
don't and again I am defending the New
York Post I'm defending any outlet that
ran with this we don't know if it's fake
news we really don't know we do know
that NASA has not issued that one yeah
but maybe NASA should that's my point
NASA get on it do you know what I mean
you know they're stargazing so much
they're not keeping their eye on on
things that could really happen I think
people need a release even in space I
don't think it's fair then come up with
a device that keeps the material
secreted uh and uh and and and and far
from uh anyone who could be impregnated
it's called the International Space
Station the tube sock all right okay
nice nicely done Sona